the controversial statement I don't know
if you saw so uh Rolo and I we do a show
every other Friday called access Vegas
and so every week we've asked uh the
girls the question about whether or not
they believe in one of the statements
that you have one of my favorite quotes
from you is women don't care about your
struggles they wait at the finish line
and they [__] the winners can you talk
about where you came up with that idea
and I'd love for your reaction because
I've we've had seven girls on before uh
just come with a reaction almost all of
them agreed with that actually it was
really interesting uh where did you come
up with that quote
yeah I mean like women don't have a lot
of patience for guys struggles
um then you always hear the arguments
well you know I've been with with my
husband for 10 15 years and he had this
struggle and that struggle and I never
left him and I stuck with him I'm like
okay great right but what do you look
like what does he look like you know did
you have options you know did he fix a
problem like there's a lot of
outside factors that can contribute that
that may that may make that variable
non-existent but on a bounce of
probabilities again you know women just
don't have time for guys that aren't
doing something with their life right oh
you know my boss was mean to me today
like I remember talking to this like I
used to talk to women often you know on
dates about why their husband would um
you know like why they would split up
with their husband because when I got
out of my divorce I mean I did what
every other dork does and starts dating
you know women their own age which are
mostly divorced and a lot of the stories
I heard was well you know he just you
know he couldn't keep a job down or he
couldn't provide or he wasn't
um you know this guy was uh we grew
apart all the time we yeah we grew apart
as my favorite one it's like no he lost
his job but we grew apart yeah yeah
there's yeah there's lots of those
stories but I mean the truth of the
matter is it all boils down to that
simple phase you know women don't care
about your struggles they do hang out at
the finish line and they pick the winner
I mean that's what they want pick them
[__] them whatever you want to call it
that's generally what their modus
apparenta is let's go for the guy that
has what I want so what I think is
really interesting so I used to work in
well I still I still work in the
financial Community mostly in stock
options so we deal with normal
distributions and when you say a lot of
the stuff you know especially with the
20 with the 20 red flags there probably
are some single mothers that you could
be with you talk about this before but
in the normal distribution the middle
68.27 what you're saying is correct as
far as what you're saying about women
don't care about your struggles that's
not 68.27 that's 99.9 I have found very
because I I this is the example I used
let's go to Walmart let's look at the
guys stocking the shelves at Walmart
he's struggling way [__] more than me
and none of you care and when we had
some girls in there and they're like
well I would care about my partner
struggles and I'm like yes but he's your
partner that means he had to have at
least enough attractiveness and enough
you build enough comfort you had enough
value he had enough value in your eyes
for him to become your partner in order
for that to happen you did not go
through all the work he did to get his
master's degree he started set first
business go through bankruptcy second
business go through the divorce you know
so whatever horrible injury had whatever
thing that happened like that you didn't
care about that you were dating a
finished product and it's funny because
we had all these girls come on and we
and Rolo and I were kind of expecting
them to disagree and none of them did
man none of them did it was really
interesting not very many women will
disagree with that I mean they might
look they might try to try to preserve
like an image about themselves because
they don't want to seem to be that way
but you know when you peel back the
layers and women become honest almost
all women will agree with that statement
it's a very difficult one to fight yeah
uh men compete women choose I also like
this one as well I mean it's really
interesting like what we got into a
discussion and the reason why I talk
about evolutionary psychology so much is
because I like an evidence-based
explanation of why men and women are
different it doesn't mean that we're not
equal I mean under the eyes of law we're
equal but uh actually we'll get into the
idea about family law but when we talk
about this this concept of us being
different for some people they have a
serious problem with it with
evolutionary psychology one of the
things that I also found with Dr Buss
and Gad sad and Stephen Pinker whoever
is the reason why I feel this is the
most testable model of psychology and it
doesn't really blow up is because people
on the right I don't like the concept of
evolution people on the left don't like
the concept of gender roles and so we
end up in this like Middle Ground where
it's almost like Galileo telling the
Pope that the the earth goes around the
Sun so they put them on house arrest it
feels a little bit like that this is and
it's almost like a red pill truth that a
lot of people even conservative people
don't want to hear
yeah absolutely I got nothing to scream
down brother yeah I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full length podcast you can find
that over here that clips from if you're
new to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out